Let's go to, Oh, I don't know.
Let's go to our caller from the nine Oh nine
area code.
Who's calling today from nine zero nine.
Hey David, it's Sam from California.
Hey Sam.
What's up?
Hey, I'm the impeachment hearings for my understanding
is about Ukraine.
Right.
And how he tried to get dirt on the Bidens
but isn't the information that Hunter was
working in that Ukrainian gas company itself,
isn't that itself the dirt that he was looking
for?
Uh, no.
So the, the, the deliverable as it's being
discussed is public announcements of investigations
on the very, very bad boys, Joe and Hunter
Biden.
That's, that's the deliverable.
The truth of whatever was going on is secondary
or even tertiary.
What Trump was concerned with was I want Ukraine
to allow ugly and publicly say the Bidens
are bad and we're investigating them and so
on and so forth.
Gotcha.
One more question.
How much political capital do you think the
GOP is willing to lose over Trump and will
they ever recover?
Well, they're clearly willing to lose more
than they've lost because actually the hearings
are so long and you know, a lot of people
just don't have time to really parse through
it that even though it has been embarrassing,
if you just look at the substance from a PR
perspective, I mean, it changed when Sunland
testified because Sunland was brutally devastating
to Trump.
But I actually, on the one hand, I think Republicans
can afford to lose quite a bit of political
capital still.
But on the other hand, as I said earlier this
week, if Democrats can't really make something
very noticeable happen as a result of these
hearings, the Democrats risk losing a lot
of political capital and maybe damaging themselves
in 2020.
Awesome.
Okay.
Thank you David.
All right, appreciate the phone call.
Thank you very quickly.
Got to the questions.
I like that.
That is a no, no big prelude or anything like
that